i want to talk today about the issue of
uh transgender sports participation
and maybe even more specifically about
trans women
in sports and there's a really specific
reason why i want to do this
last week i got a call and as many of
you know when we do
calls they can be about anything i'm not
prepared for them i'm just answering and
the topics can be anything and i give my
thoughts at the time
and someone called in who said they're
on the left
they're not transphobic they support
trans rights
at every opportunity and yet they said
they recognize that having individuals
born biologically male
participating in women's sports confers
an advantage
at a physical level that didn't make
sense to them and i said
not knowing a lot about it that i also
didn't fully understand the logic
but i was aware of the fact that the
right often
cynically wants to make this the issue
about trans rights when the reality is
it's really not the major issue that
that make it out to be
and it's often used as a way to subtly
push back against trans rights more
broadly and today i want to expand on my
comments because
i actually had some time over the
weekend to research the issue in more
detail and the more i learn about it the
more convinced i am
that it is a fabricated wedge issue
meant to divide people and in particular
to predispose people to be against
trans rights as i researched the issue
one of the things i learned
is that hormone replacement therapy
which trans women
often avail themselves of over a one to
two year period
comes close to completely eliminating
the performance gap that we
might imagine exists in some sports when
you have individuals born biologically
male
competing against those born
biologically female
now i want to put aside for a second the
absolutely hysterical notion that
some cisgendered men might quote pretend
to be trans women and go through
testosterone blocking treatment
merely to compete in women's sports
without actually
genuinely being trans someone willing to
do that
has bigger issues that need to be
resolved but it's it's it's
so uncommon that it's not really the
issue the reality is that a study from
2015
called race times for transgender
athletes
shows that trans women have essentially
no advantage in running
over cisgendered women after a period of
roughly a year
of hormone replacement therapy there's
another more recent study which showed
that
after one year there is still a modest
advantage for trans women
and that the length of time with the
hormone replacement therapy
maybe should be longer but to get from
that the idea that this is some kind of
you know woke cabal looking to impose
mike tyson or his physical equivalent
into women's wrestling against
18 year old girls as an example that's a
cartoon
that that's ridiculous to suggest that
that's predominantly the situation that
that exists in the world and i got a few
dozen emails about this
and i was completely genuine when i said
last week
i've not studied this enough but at face
value
it does raise some questions for me i
still believe this is a complicated
issue but the issue of trans
sports is one of many issues related to
trans rights and its importance is being
dramatically inflated by certain groups
of people
for cynical political goals and what i
mean by that
is that trans people intersex
individuals they didn't just start
existing in the last five years
sports organizations endocrinologists
and others they've known about this for
a really long time
and many institutions deal with these
things on a case-by-case basis so
when i hear about a political movement
that has this knee-jerk reaction to
immediately say
no trans women in women's sports period
it either
is coming from just an ignorant place or
a place of very bad faith so
i'm glad to have learned more about it
and to be able to say more and that
doesn't mean all my questions are
answered
with a whole bunch of sports this is not
really an issue
with a certain category of sports this
is in theory
an issue and we have to look at hormone
replacement therapy
actual performance differences after one
or two year periods
and i tweeted about this yesterday and a
few people wrote to me and they said oh
but there's this particular case where
someone's skull was broken by a trans
woman okay i'm not saying that there are
no
issues what i am saying is that
pretending this is the issue
about uh trans rights is
wrong i'm not going to say necessarily
that it's coming from
bad faith it could be ignorance but it's
wrong to say this is the issue
it has to be dealt with on a
case-by-case basis and the other thing i
would point out is
the people that were replying to my
tweet kept talking about the two or
three
individual instances where else would
these folks say
that because of two or three instances
of something
we need to completely change all of the
legal and regulatory infrastructure look
at the number of people that are
killed by guns and yet they say oh yeah
but i mean you know a few hundred
incidents that's
that's not enough to justify changing
the rules uh
but yet here everybody's pointing to the
same two or three incidents over the
last five years and saying that
justifies
creating an entirely new regulatory and
legal apparatus it just doesn't pass the
sniff test for me and i've been glad to
to learn more about it doesn't mean
every question is answered
doesn't mean that there aren't some
problems to solve or questions to deal
with
uh but i think we need to understand the
sort of cynical nature that exists by
among those who pretend this is the
issue
and um use it as a smoke screen to deny
trans rights more broadly and
unfortunately that's what's happening
all too often